you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 7
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Anandi Carlsen going into
this round Carlson has a 4 to 2 lead
over andand and Anand with the white
pieces in this one opens with E 4 we
have seen this in every game by Anand
when he has the white pieces we have yet
to deviate from the e4 start and we
follow game 6 up until this point right
here where instead of c3 the game 6 move
we have the bishop capturing the knight
giving up the bishop pair in exchange
for damaging black structure following
up Knight d2 black pins the knight a
question is thrown to the bishop that
pin is maintained and now we don't go
forward with this approach to break the
pin but rather to challenge the bishop
by way of Knight g3 Knight d7 is a quite
common maneuver on the black end with
this structure where he pivots on d7 to
watch over a 5 and will one day maybe
like to get to the e6 square by way of
f8 or even c5 so following up being
quite consistent like g3 black gives up
the bishop pair and well the other
consideration was to drop back here but
black simply captures simplifies the
position more and now tries to show that
the knight on G 3 is going to be
inconvenienced with the g6 now around
the knight it's tough to get him working
you know I'm not so sure where the
perfect home would be for this night so
this should be three getting all the
pieces working both sides now queenside
castle now entering a position where we
have some race against one another's
king if there were opposite sides
castling that's what we would like to do
not the case here the night gets working
he was doing nothing on g3 and with rook
to e8 this is aimed at
preventing D for if this was even a
thought by white it's certainly now
going to be a bad one efore would then
fall so we wouldn't have d4 first king
b1 quite common when you queenside
castle get that king over a little bit
more to watch over those pawns on a two
or a seven b6 is there black King gets
ready to tuck himself in on b7 and here
comes h4 which is intending h5 and the
opening of the H file for this rook King
b7 was played pretty quick the other
thought was to just stop this idea all
together with h5 and I'm not so sure why
that move wasn't played but King b7
certainly not a bad move of course and
this particular structure keep in mind
on the black side the pawns on
b6 c6 and c7 they act as very good
defense to any Queen checks if we were
to get into Queen versus Queen endgame
or really just for as long as the
Queen's are on the board c7 pawn is
around to negate any rank checks the
b-pawn of course for file checks and now
this doubled pawn serves a good role in
stopping any diagonal checks so a nice
little pocket a nice home for the King
in order to avoid any petrol checks it's
not as so easy on the white side if
there's ever some pawn move there's
maybe one day a way a queen could be
making use of the f1 and c4 c4 squares
to be giving check whether he's on B 1
or a 2 anyhow
you don't really get to see that in this
game but just take note of that
defensive structure on the black side h5
comes
dark-squared bishop scum off and this is
where we can really have the last real
structural change in the game was the
Queen was recapturing but if the pawn
takes now this file is opened up and
well how will black cope with some
pressure against the F pawn
let's make a semi passing move a five I
think that there could always be you
could defend with the rook but I believe
maybe even keeping the pawn on f6 and
with this night here I don't know how
much more you can break down this
structure here on the black side was
another approach that white could have
taken but instead it was keeping the
structure as is taking with the Queen
the knight posts up on c5 c6 maybe even
Knight a 4 with Queen B 4 ideas of
putting pressure on b2 or maybe around
the corner the H file is now opened and
with g3 this is a tell that f4 is going
to be played next or sometimes very very
soon so that if there is a capture white
is able to recapture with the pun we
have a 5 looking at maybe disrupting the
White King side structure b3 you would
need to be very careful about playing
this move because of blacks reply a4 if
a black pawn is allowed on a3 that's
going to be very troublesome to the
white king taking away his flight square
maybe one day the Queen could get there
and cause white a giant headache so we
don't have b3 u get active the rook had
complete control over the H file so the
next thing to look to do is how exactly
to function laterally not really a more
active square for that rip than h7 that
is challenged right away pair of Brooks
comes off and the pressure is going to
now be alleviated from f7 by first
playing Queen f6 stopping additional
pressure against that point and
preparing to exchange off an inactive
rook for a very active one with rook to
h8 so f4 is played rook h8 is there and
we have the rooks coming off right away
and keep in mind there is no in-between
capture
this square with let's say even some
follow-up like this that's not working
out because keep in mind after this
capture there is a queen check and then
you are losing the rook
so this needed to be calculated from
this point here anticipating f4 knowing
that when you play here and after this
capture capture pawn takes here
recaptured this these moves were all
played in the game you needed to know as
black how to respond after d4 you needed
to see all of that and know that there
is a way out of the tactic because there
are unprotected pieces unprotected
pieces lead to tactics and lead to ways
out of tactics as well Queen takes here
there's no time to take the knight the
Queen is hit he takes Queen Knight takes
Queen black would be up upon so we
wouldn't have that we do have however
this position springing about in the
game where the Queen recaptures on e5
and the follow up Queen f3 pressure on
f7 f5 is there we have these pawns
exchanged and not really much going on
at this point
c3 at this point looking to get the King
into c2 one point I can make is instead
of f5 I had thought during the game what
should white do if Knight a4 converging
on b2 well you do need to be a little
bit careful if d4 this is a bad move due
to Queen B 5 this pawn is still being
hit as well as the knight make could be
defended with b3 but this is losing as a
result of Queen takes Knight followed up
with a fork so that wouldn't be the
defense what would if Knight a4 were
played on this move 26 well we play c3
and if the queen is coming over here you
would have b3 c3 point is covered if the
night plays here King c2 would be played
every base point is covered now this
Queen
is a bit offside f7 is still hit and
this night is ready to jump into the
center and kick the Queen back so this
is not a road to go down for black so we
didn't have Knight to a4 instead it was
f5 pawns are exchanged c3 is there the
king is ready to contribute night II 6
these Knights are basically offsetting
one another these squares being covered
d4 and F for King c2 Knight g5 Queen f2
and what we end up having is something
that is quite similar to games 1 and 2
of this match this game is this position
is debt equal and we just witnessed
another threefold repetition this game
ending this game 7 ending as a draw and
with that the match now Carlsen having
four and a half points to anons
two and a half points and we take things
into round eight where Carlson will have
the white pieces so we will see what
takes place at that point and I look
forward to it as usual so that's all for
this video take care bye
you